es ist eine neue aufgespürte spezies die
uns bei der besiedlung anderer planeten
extrem nützlich werden könnte bereits
vor sechs jahren wurden an verschiedenen
orten der internationalen raumstation
iss proben genommen jetzt ist klar was
ich in diesen proben die ganze zeit
versteckt hielt und diese spezies könnte
uns beim anbau von pflanzen auf dem mars
nützlich sein klick zum science im
future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank an jakob für
den dem vorschlag der uns über klicks um
science in future und zwar hat die
telegate gruppe erreicht hat der link
dazu ist hier unter oder in der video
beschreibung die mikroben mitbewohner
die jetzt auf der iss entdeckt wurden
haben jahrelang mit den astronauten und
astronauten an bord am selben tisch
gesessen muss man sagen bereits vor
sechs jahren nämlich zwischen 2015 und
2016 hatten forschende proben an
verschiedenen stellen der ss nehmen
lassen unter anderem vom esstisch von
einem regal das für die lagerung
wissenschaftlicher instrumente genutzt
wird und eine weiter probe von der
kuppel der station
das alles geschah im rahmen des nasa
experiments microbial tracking und eine
aktuelle studie lüftet jetzt endlich das
geheimnis und zwar konnten in den proben
der ss bakterien der familie mit thilo
bakteriums identifiziert werden und
diese mikroben könnten für die weitere
erforschung vor allem auch besiedlung
des weltraums durch uns menschen eine
extrem wichtige rolle spielen
bakterien im weltall zu diesem thema gab
es bereits einige studien und
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichungen zum
beispiel war ein internationales
forschungsteam erst vor kurzem der frage
nachgegangen ob bakterien überhaupt das
vakuum des weltalls überleben können
denn klar ist eigentlich handelt es sich
um einen extrem lebensfeindlich nord bei
sonneneinstrahlung kann es zu
temperaturen bis zu plus 100 grad
celsius kommt aber auch minus 270 grad
celsius sind möglich genau deswegen
brauchen wir menschen also eine
schutzausrüstung um uns sicher durch den
weltraum zu bewegen doch wie sieht das
bei bakterien aus noch dazu wurden
experimente auf daher ist es
durchgeführt konkret hatten die
fachleute bakterien
des stammes den fokus radio du runs für
drei jahre an der außenhülle der
internationalen raumstation iss den
krassen bedingungen des weltalls
ausgesetzt und hier sind es ja nicht nur
extreme temperaturschwankungen sondern
auch das vakuum das die existenz von
leben erschwert oder sogar unmöglich
macht an bord einer space extrakte
wurden die paket sei es gemacht und
wurden dort auf platten aufgebracht die
dann durch an mechanischen abend von der
außenhülle der iss ins all gehalten
wurde
drei ganze jahre dauerte dieses
experiment ehe die bakterien dann viele
an bord der iss geholt wurden und das
ergebnis war verblüffend denn die
bakterien hatten tatsächlich überlebt
die fachleute fanden zwar heraus dass
die äußere schutzschicht der bakterien
ab gestorben war
doch das erbgut hatte keineswegs schaden
genommen ganz im gegenteil die bakterien
hatten eine art schutzschirm für die dna
gebildet die ihm nur kokus radio duran
verfügt nach angaben des forschungsteams
sogar über eine art selbstheilung so
werden beschädigte teile der dna stränge
durch kopien ersetzt die fachleute gehen
nach der analyse ihres experiments sogar
davon aus dass diese bakterien eine
reise von der erde zum mars überstehen
würden und zwar ungeschützt heißt also
im klartext auch im eigentlich
lebensfeindlichen weltall können
bakterien überleben ein weiterer großer
forschungserfolg konnte vor drei jahren
im jahr 2018 verbucht werden damals war
es ein forschungsteam der nasa erstmals
gelungen bakterien mit einem test direkt
an bord der uss zu identifizieren das
war damals wirklich eine große sensation
denn dadurch wird die erforschung des
weltraums durch uns menschen sehr viel
einfacher und risikoärmer der grund
dafür
mikroben im weltall können für die
astronauten und astronauten an bord der
raumschiffe zu einem großen risiko
werden denn im all ist eine erkrankung
natürlich noch einmal eine verschärfte
situation denn hier kann medizinische
hilfe anders als auf der erde nicht in
vollem umfang gewährleistet werden in
der vergangenheit bestand die einzige
möglichkeit darin die proben in
entsprechender labore auf der erde zu
bringen eine aufwendige und
kostenintensive sache also
herausgekommen war hierbei ein
zweistufiger prozess mit dem namen jeans
ins pastry wobei der gesamte prozess
tatsächlich komplett an bord der iss
stattfinden kann sprich gefährliche
bakterien können im fall der fälle
dort identifiziert werden standardmäßig
läuft das allerdings noch nicht heißt
also die nun entdeckten bakterien sind
längst nicht die ersten die auf der ice
s entdeckt wurden bereits seit vielen
jahren wird die station strengen
mikrobiologisch überwacht acht
verschiedene standorte werden dazu
regelmäßig analysiert insgesamt wurden
so laut angaben der nasa bereits
hunderte bakterien proben von der ss
genauer untersucht 1000 proben warten
noch auf die reise zur erde um dann dort
genauer unter die lupe genommen zu
werden
dazu heißt es von seiten der nasa
natürlich handelt es sich bei der iss um
eine saubere gepflegte umgebung die
sicherheit der besatzung hat oberste
priorität daher ist es wichtig die
krankheitserreger von mensch und pflanze
zu verstehen dennoch ist es auch wichtig
erkenntnisse über solche nützlichen
mikroben wie das neuartige methode
bakterium mali zu sammeln
zurück zu der aktuellen studie und den
insgesamt vier mitschüler bakterium
bakterienstämme die nun in den proben
aufgespürt werden konnten klar ist bei
dem so genannten methode bakterium ag
mali handelt es sich um ein ganz
besonders interessantes paket zu tun
haben wir es mit einem beweglichen
grampositiven basilius der zwischen 25
und 30 grad wächst auf der erde ist
diese spezies fast überall zu hause auf
pflanzen in der luft im wasser und auf
sedimenten in der fachwelt gehört es zur
ordnung der sogenannten rizzo beales die
sogenannten symbiotischen bakterien der
pflanzen und genau das lässt die
forschenden der nasa aufhorchen denn
diese methode parteien sind für die
pflanzen super wichtig da sich
stickstoff fixieren nur mit diesem
element kann eine pflanze wachsen auch
das element phosphat erhalten die
pflanzen indirekt durch die hilfe des
pflanzen symbiotischen bakteriums denn
diese ermöglichen die sogenannte
mobilisierung von phosphat vereinfacht
gesagt sind die bakterien dem pflanzen
also sehr nützlich da sie an organischen
fonds voraus unlöslichen verbindungen
lösen können was noch dazu kommt die
bakterien ermöglichten es den pflanzen
mit angriffen von krankheitserregern
besser zurechtgekommen und auch mit
abiotische stress besser umzugehen dazu
schreibt das nasa forschungsteam in der
aktuellen pressemitteilung und pflanzen
an standorten zu züchten an denen die
ressourcen minimal sind ist die
identifizierung neuer mikroben die das
pflanzenwachstum unter stressigen
bedingungen fördern unerlässlich heißt
also im klartext wir könnten uns diese
bakterien zu nutze machen um auf fremden
planeten pflanzen anzubauen und
möglicherweise sogar ja eine art
landwirtschaft zu betreiben
hinsichtlich der pläne einer mars
kolonie könnten diese erkenntnisse von
großem nutzen sein
legen die bakterien mit dem namen metall
oratorium ali also den grundstein der
agrarwirtschaft für künftige maß
kolonien fest steht jedenfalls wenn wir
menschen auf dem mond oder mars siedeln
wollen brauchen wir dort auch nahrung
entweder eingeflogen oder aber
praktischerweise direkt vor ort
kultiviert möglich wurde das durch ein
in sich geschlossenes gewächshaus das
auch im weltraum sichere ernten sorgen
könnte an solch einer idee tüfteln
beispielsweise das deutsche zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt der name des projekts
ids es hierbei handelt es sich
tatsächlich um ein modell gewächshaus
der zukunft das bereits ein jahr lang in
der antarktis auf seinen ernteertrag
getestet wurde und zwar mit erfolg
innerhalb eines jahres konnten insgesamt
117 kilogramm salat 46 kilo tomaten 67
kilo gurken 19 kilogramm 15 kilo kräuter
und acht kilo radieschen geerntet werden
die pflanzen wachsen hier ohne erde
tageslicht und pestizide
das forschungsteam konnte von bremen aus
beobachten was im gewächshaus passiert
kameras und monitore zeigen nicht nur
den sauerstoff und den
kohlendioxidgehalt an sondern auch die
temperatur feuchtigkeit computer
gesteuert wurden die wurzeln der
pflanzen mit einer nährstofflösung
gespielt und zwar alle fünf minuten
zudem bekamen sie extra kohlendioxid und
licht und all das sorgte dafür dass die
pflanzen schneller wuchsen als unter
normalen bedingungen ähnlich soll das
szenario dann auch bei einer echten
raumfahrt mission aussehen
von der erde aus könnte die pflanzen
aufzucht bereits gestartet werden wenn
die astronauten und astronauten sich auf
den weg machen dazu daniel schubert vom
dlr
wenn die astronauten am mars ankommen
soll das gewächshaus schon in voller
blüte stehen und auch für die ehre
könnte das indoor farming die lösung
sein um der zerstörung der umwelt durch
die landwirtschaft einhalt zu gebieten
doch dann könnten auch großkonzerne die
gesamte nahrungsmittelversorgung über
nehmen und das ist wirklich nicht das
was man sich wünschen kann wegen
umweltzerstörungen landwirtschaft wird
durch großkonzerne abgelöst anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren ganz wichtiges
thema pixum sunsim future bis dann
bleibt dran